the amazing spider-man 2 that's right my
series of spider-man reviews has brought
us here
now I've reviewed this film before
obviously when it came out a couple
years ago and this is one of those rare
instances where my opinion has
drastically changed usually when I see a
film it's like yeah that's how I feel I
know how I feel and if there's a change
it's minut you know I mean you go back
and watch a movie sometimes you
appreciate something a little more or
maybe something drags because you've
seen it before but most of the time
I always know exactly how I feel when I
see a film and the first time I saw the
amazing spider-man 2 I said it was okay
I gave it a b-minus and I said that I
appreciated the fact that there wasn't
another origin story the fact that we'd
have to sit through Peter Parker and
Uncle Ben and it gets shot and oh we got
bit by a spider again also I do recall
that when I first saw the amazing
spider-man 2 it was one of the first
movies I saw after getting over a
terrible flu virus that I had so maybe
in some weird way I was in an incredible
mood and more forgiving than I usually
am because upon rewatch I really don't
like this movie the film opens again
with Peter Parker's parents and it's
trying to make that story interesting
it's trying to give us something we
haven't seen before the untold story we
were supposed to get in the amazing
spider-man but actually didn't get it
was the exact same story again it wasn't
untold all was the same thing again
Uncle Ben got shot and it's terrible and
now he has powers so we get a weird
Bourne Identity ripoff fight scene in a
plane taking place in the past where
they had current modern-day Sony Vaio
laptops that didn't exist when this
scene took place the suit in this film
is better that's the one thing I can
definitely say is an improvement on the
last one the suit is like the comics it
doesn't look like a basketball anymore
it looks fantastic amazing the eyepieces
are huge it's all really great visually
appealing but when we start out with
spider-man like as high as he is I just
want to know how he got there is he
falling from a plane skydiving did he
attached himself to a helicopter this is
an issue with other Spiderman posters
almost every spider-man poster has him
like soaring above the city like he can
physically fly how do you get up there
but this is the first time in a move
beware you're just like wait that is he
falling through the clouds so let's talk
about Paul Giamatti when I say six Avex
Wow Jamie Foxx is also in this film and
he plays electro I don't mind him so
much you do feel some sympathy for him
but he's essentially the Riddler from
Batman Forever he obsesses over
spider-man just like Jim Carrey obsessed
over Batman he has this strange office
with pictures of spider-man everywhere
he talks to himself he's this reclusive
nerdy scientist that no one else
respects it is almost like Joel
Schumacher made this movie it's it's
actually scary
so the rhinos going around causing all
this destruction and spider-man decides
to hang around and tell some jokes
instead of just stopping him look at
what happens next all of this
destruction and chaos and possible life
loss
but he could have just stopped if he
wouldn't have told those quips that the
fans wanted to hear so much that the
screenwriters just were like hey we have
to please the fans who cares about
making a coherent film and portraying
spider-man as a hero that saves lives he
wants to tell some jokes while causing a
shit-ton of destruction in his path
along the way this entire opening
sequence is edited so poorly it goes
from Gwen giving this speech she's the
valedictorian back to rhino back to
Jamie Foxx back to spider-man and it's
all of these clashing tones and you
realize that really the entire film is
actually going to be like that a bunch
of tones everywhere just clashing with
each other trying to make a coherent
film in some way and again Gwen has no
real reason to be here she's just Gwen
Stacy what is her character she doesn't
have a character she doesn't do anything
she's just Gwen Stacy she's off and on
with Peter Peter's off and on with her
she's happy she's sad she goes from all
of these highs and lows emotionally
throughout the script and Emma Stone's
performance to where all of a sudden at
the end she's just like hey this is my
life this is my decision and I'm gonna
help you with the Green Goblin problem
and you can't do anything about it
I'm not messing around you can't be here
right now this is why nobody makes my
decisions for me all right no but this
is my choice okay my choice Oh mine I
gotta say though my favorite part of
this film is this one little tiny scene
where this kids getting picked on and
Spidey rescues him and fixes his little
windmill that he made and just walks off
with him that spider-man that is firemen
that scene is spider-man they absolutely
nailed that character but it doesn't
actually have much impact on the film
except later the kid comes back and
stands in front of the Rhino in the
spider-man costume and that's I guess
where that scene comes into play but
that scene for me is the best part of
this whole movie and a perfect capturing
of the spider-man character for whatever
reason they just couldn't continue that
for the extremely bloated runtime of
this film dane dehaan who i normally
love plays Harry Osborn in this film
terribly it's a lot of slow methodical
talk and my father's dead he died from a
disease that I now have and this disease
is going to kill me very soon
Peter despite the fact that my dad died
after like 60 years just give me your
blood okay this whole subplot with Harry
Osborn with this disease Norman Osborn
has the same disease it's passed on
through hereditary genes but for
whatever reason it took Norman Osborn a
really long time to die
but Harry has like I don't know like no
time he's dying like right now it makes
no sense it's just this terrible plot
device to get Harry to want Spiderman's
blood to put inside of him too maybe
combat against this disease because
Peters been infected with something
along those lines because some kind of
experiments with his dad because Oscorp
and there's a secret underground train
that rises out of from the subway when
Peter finds their coins inside the
calculator and then inside the Train
there's a computer message that his
father planned all these years to just
have Underground and he found the coins
and it somehow it worked
who wrote this what the fuck
Sony had to have gotten their nasty
little hands in there and said this is
what we want the Green Goblin in this
movie isn't Dane DeHaan it's Sony Sony's
the Green Goblin they're in the corner
haha fight a man we have you now
spider-man Jamie Foxx as electro was
hilarious when he turns into electro it
repairs the gap in his teeth like
electricity goes and fixes the gap that
is so dumb the electricity repairs his
teeth the majority of this film is Peter
Parker and Gwen Stacy walking around
doing improvisational humor maybe sort
of making faces and scratching their
noses and going ha ha ha ha and then
they'll be big bloated action scenes
with tons of CGI and Hans Zimmer's very
bad idea of a dubstep theme I really
don't know what happened there it's my
birthday time to light my candles
rajanbabu trucks truck about it about
hibachi but my favorite part of the
entire scene were electro attacks Times
Square with electricity flying
everywhere is the fact that throughout
this entire scene gwen stacy is grabbing
a metal bar she's just such a smart
character she's has to be there this is
her life Peter I have to be here Peter I
make my own decisions Peter because I'm
Gwen Stacy no you're gonna fucking die
because you just had to be there for
some reason now I've been on YouTube for
like a long time almost ten years seven
years on on this stuff that I'm doing
now but before that I had other channels
as well so I know how YouTube works
that's why when they show this guy who
has a YouTube video he has two
subscribers two hundred and fifty seven
thousand views and 92 likes yeah that
doesn't make sense unless he paid for
views which by the way side point don't
buy views you have to be a moron to not
be able to tell when someone buys views
they have like 50 comments on their
video and 500,000 views I wonder if they
bought fake views the other thing about
the amazing spider-man 2 is that it
constantly tries to set up the sinister
six there are so many references to it
and it's sad we watching it now knowing
that that's not going to happen because
it just feels like a giant set up
trailer movie that doesn't have a story
of its own and just exists to bring
these villains together and hopefully
make more but they did such a shitty job
making this film interesting that no one
wants more even people who were fans of
Andrew Garfield and his portrayal were
like you got to do better than that guys
I mean there are so many things I'm not
even mentioning like the fact that when
Harry turns into the Green Goblin he can
just instantly fly his glider he has no
training has no idea what he's doing
really but apparently he does he's
perfect at it in the first spider-man
film Norman was one of the people that
designed that glider so it makes sense
that he could fly it perfectly or Peter
talking to Gwen across this giant space
of electricity flying everywhere and you
can just hear him fine through this
bunker glass window it's so so bad and
did I mention that electro plays a song
he plays the itsy bitsy spider song with
electricity
so like I said earlier Gwen dies because
she just had to show up to the big
showdown with lightning monsters and
genetically-altered
spider people it'd be like me just
walking into a war zone because it's my
choice to be there with no military
training no weaponry just just me just
walking into a war zone with mines and
explosions and gunfire of course I'm
gonna die it just doesn't make you feel
for her character at all she's supposed
to be so smart she's the valedictorian
of her entire school yet she's grabbing
metal bars when electricity is flying
everywhere and she's showing up to the
giant big showdown with superhero people
because she just wants to be there a
guess of course she's gonna die this is
what these two amazing spider-man films
have done the first one was like hey
look we have to appeal to all the people
who didn't like Raimi's all the haters
of rama's films we have to appeal to
them so he has to tell more jokes he has
to have web shooters and he has to be
like super smart and create all kinds of
stuff even though he has no money the
second film is like hey people didn't
like how Mary Jane was a damsel in
distress will make gwen stacy just you
know she'll do everything she'll always
show up by her own will it's just
they're trying to do whatever is
different from the first Raimi films and
I understand why they would feel that
way they want to appeal to the haters of
those films even though those have
seriously diminished over the years
because of how shitty these two films
were the simple fact is though they
don't tell a cohesive story it doesn't
make sense they're just trying to appeal
to a demographic they're just trying to
appease certain people they're not
trying to make a great film that's it
Gwen Stacy dies the movie ends Green
Goblin is in a prison and he's like it
comes and goes his disease apparently
just went away for a while and came back
and he can control it now I don't know
and there's the guy in the Hat walking
around vultures wings and doc Ock's arms
things we all saw in the trailers in the
final shot which we all saw in the
trailers Giamatti is so bad here I mean
laughably bad the movie ends and it's
142 minutes along which is really long
for this film and that's without deleted
scenes and there's a lot of deleted
scenes including an entire other
character played by shailene woodley
shailene woodley was going to be in this
film as Mary Jane Watson and they
completely
moved her she's not even in the deleted
scenes this movie was a clusterfuck man
amazing spider-man 2 is really bad the
only thing that saves it is a couple
scenes with spider-man really I have no
idea what they were thinking I'm gonna
give this film a D those are my thoughts
on the spider-man films i loved
spiderman in Silla war I think they
really nailed the character I can't wait
for homecoming guys what are your
thoughts on the spider-man films which
ones do you love which ones do you hate
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes